This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. It's 5.25am outside of the city hall in Peter Merritt's Berg, South Africa, and Shahita Tungo is ready to go on a run. She's wearing a white running skirt and knee socks, one pink, one blue, and she's cracking jokes. Listen, I'm not there to run for the money, so I have to look good. I choose my struggles. I can't be fast, so I must be cute. The road around her is packed with other equally chipper runners, adjusting the race numbers,
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。南非彼得马里茨堡的市政厅外，时间是凌晨5点25分，沙希达·通戈正准备去跑步。她穿着一条白色跑步裙，脚蹬及膝袜，一只粉色，一只蓝色，嘴里还开着玩笑。“听着，我不是为了钱去跑的，所以我得穿得好看点。我选择我的挣扎。我跑不快，所以我必须可爱。”她周围的道路上挤满了同样兴高采烈的跑者，他们正在调整参赛号码，
snapping selfies, and dancing. Altogether, there are about 13,000 people here, and they're not getting ready for a 5K or a 10K or even a marathon. This is the start line of the comrades, which is 56 miles long. That's Ryan Lenora Brown, reporter in South Africa who was there the morning of the race in August. Most years, more than 15,000 people run the comrades, way more than run any other ultramarathon in the world.
自拍，跳舞。这里总共有大约13000人，他们准备的不是5公里、10公里，甚至不是马拉松。这是“同志马拉松”（Comrades Marathon）的起跑线，全程56英里。那是瑞安·莱诺拉·布朗，一位在8月比赛当天身处现场的南非记者。大多数年份里，有超过15000人参加同志马拉松，远超世界上任何其他超级马拉松。
For reference, about 25,000 people ran the last Boston marathon, but the comrades is more than twice as long. And as a foreigner in South Africa, I've been haunted for a long time by a question. Why the hell do South Africans think running a race like this for fun is a normal thing to do. Not only is it very, very long, the comrades goes to a part of South Africa whose name sounds pretty ominous when you're doing two back-to-back marathons through it. The Valley of a Thousand Hills.
作为参考，大约有25000人参加了上一届波士顿马拉松，但同志马拉松的长度是它的两倍多。作为一名在南非的外国人，我长期以来一直被一个问题困扰：为什么南非人会觉得为了好玩而参加这样的比赛是一件正常的事情？同志马拉松不仅非常、非常长，而且它经过南非的一个地方，当你连续跑两个马拉松穿过它时，它的名字听起来相当不祥——“千丘之谷”。
How are you? Good, good, good, good, good, can I'm looking forward to it. Shihita is one of the Comrades' Pacers, who are appointed by the race to help groups of runners trying to finish in a certain time. In South Africa, these Pacers are called bus drivers, and the people they pace are their bus. Shaheeda paces the Comrade's slowest bus, made up of runners trying to finish just before the race's 12-hour cutoff. She's a kind of evangelist for running very slowly, very far.
“你好吗？”“很好，很好，很好，我非常期待。”沙希达是同志马拉松的配速员之一，他们由赛事方指定，帮助那些试图在特定时间内完成比赛的跑者群体。在南非，这些配速员被称为“公交车司机”，而他们带领的人就是他们的“乘客”。沙希达带领的是同志马拉松最慢的一班“公交车”，由那些试图在比赛12小时关门时间前完赛的跑者组成。她是那种“跑得极慢、极远”的传道者。
I just want to make the slower runners like myself believe that the how is irrelevant, whether you crawling or rolling or whatever, as long as you're going forward it converts you are going forward. Today she's got a little piece of paper tucked into her pocket, telling her what times and distances she needs to hit to come in just under that 12 hour mark. Basically she's aiming to do this like a human metronome, 13-minute miles all day long. No faster and definitely no slower.
“我只是想让像我一样的慢速跑者相信，‘怎么跑’并不重要，无论是爬还是滚，只要你在前进，你就是在前进。”今天，她口袋里塞着一张小纸条，上面写着她需要达到的时间和距离，以确保在12小时大关前完赛。基本上，她的目标是像人类节拍器一样，全天保持每英里13分钟的配速。不能更快，绝对不能更慢。
Over the course of the day, they'll follow a route that weaves through what feels like all of South Africa. The race winds through wealthy suburbs full of cafes and craft breweries and sleepy run down little farming towns. It cuts across the sugar cane plantations that first brought British colonizers to this region in the 1800s. There are shack settlements and rich private schools.
在这一天里，他们将沿着一条蜿蜒穿过南非全境的路线奔跑。比赛穿过充满咖啡馆和精酿啤酒厂的富裕郊区，也经过沉睡破败的小农镇。它横跨了19世纪最初将英国殖民者带到该地区的甘蔗种植园。那里既有棚户区，也有昂贵的私立学校。
A few minutes after I see Shahida, they play the national anthem, and then another song comes on. Shoshunosa. It's a haunting tune that migrant laborers used to sing on their long journeys home from South Africa's gold mines. It's refrain means go forward. They were underground and it was dark.
在我见到沙希达几分钟后，现场播放了国歌，接着响起了另一首歌——《Shosholoza》。这是一首令人难忘的曲子，是外来劳工在从南非金矿回家的漫长旅途中常唱的歌。它的副歌意思是“前进”。他们当时在地下，四周一片漆黑。
It's a very draining task to do and that's exactly what comrades is. You know, you're going to try to along the whole day. So it is just saying, I can't do it. I will show Sholosa on, I will move on, I will keep going and no matter how hard it is, I have a purpose why I'm doing this. And then the cannon goes off. Then you start to watch. And we off. and we off. Around the world, ultra-marathons are having a moment.
“这是一项非常耗费体力的任务，而这正是同志马拉松的意义所在。你知道，你要尝试跑一整天。所以它只是在说，我能做到。我会前进，我会继续走下去，无论多么艰难，我都有坚持下去的理由。”然后大炮响了。比赛开始。我们出发了。我们出发了。在世界各地，超级马拉松正变得越来越流行。
These are races that are any distance longer than a standard 26.2 mile marathon. The number of people running them more than quadrupled between 2010 and 2020. There are now thousands of these races annually. But in most of the world, ultras are pretty niche, and they attract a very particular demographic. Your average Ultra runner in the US or Europe is a well-educated married man about 45 years old. In other words, they look a lot like me. And you only have to eyeball the start line of an Ultramarathon in North America or Europe
这些比赛的距离都超过了标准的26.2英里马拉松。2010年至2020年间，参加这些比赛的人数增加了四倍多。现在每年有成千上万场此类比赛。但在世界大部分地区，超级马拉松仍然相当小众，吸引着非常特定的人群。美国或欧洲的普通超级马拉松跑者是受过良好教育、已婚、45岁左右的男性。换句话说，他们看起来很像我。你只需要看一眼北美或欧洲超级马拉松的起跑线，
to see that this is still an overwhelmingly white sport. But in South Africa it's a different story. So all kinds of people run comrades. White, black, Indian, colored, male, female, others, wealthy, poor. If you live in South Africa you definitely know someone who runs altrues, probably lots of someone's. Here Ultramarathons are the stuff of a whole country's New Year's resolutions and midlife crises. They're the kind of thing that a totally ordinary, not athletic person wakes up one day and decides they're going to do.
就会发现这仍然是一项绝大多数由白人参与的运动。但在南非，情况则完全不同。各种各样的人都参加同志马拉松：白人、黑人、印度裔、有色人种、男性、女性、其他人，富人、穷人。如果你住在南非，你肯定认识参加超级马拉松的人，可能还认识很多。在这里，超级马拉松是一个国家的新年决心和中年危机的缩影。这是一个完全普通、不爱运动的人某天醒来决定要去做的事情。
And then does. It might be your doctor, your kid's teacher, the man pumping your gas, the woman who cleans your house. In one of the most economically unequal countries in the world, extreme distance running is a sport that feels like it includes everybody. And improbably, that inclusiveness happened during one of the darkest, most divided moments in South Africa's history, during the final years of apartheid. When the Comrades' Ultramarathon first started, it wasn't the little rainbow nation and
然后他们真的去做了。可能是你的医生、你孩子的老师、给你加油的男人、打扫你房子的女人。在这个世界上经济最不平等的国家之一，超长距离跑步是一项让人感觉包容所有人的运动。不可思议的是，这种包容性发生在南非历史上最黑暗、最分裂的时刻之一——种族隔离制度的最后几年。当同志马拉松刚开始时，它并不是后来那种“彩虹之国”和
Nike's that it later became. In fact, in its earliest days, the Comrades looked a lot like Ultramarathons elsewhere. So back then, look, I mean, this is 1921. This is South Africa in its early days. This is Matzalani Mama Bolo. He's a South African sports journalist. And also, like so many of his countrymen, a comrades runner. The race was only open to white people. It was just the white people who ran and only made, actually.
耐克鞋的天下。事实上，在早期，同志马拉松看起来和其他超级马拉松没什么两样。“回到1921年，这是南非的早期。这是马扎拉尼·马马博洛。他是一位南非体育记者，也像他的许多同胞一样，是一位同志马拉松跑者。”比赛只对白人开放。当时只有白人参加，而且实际上只有男性。
The comrades was started by a white South African World War I veteran named Vic Klappum. To honor his comrades who had fallen in the war, he designed a run between his hometown of Peter Meritzburg and the coastal city of Durban about 56 miles away. And a few people apparently signed up. I think there was about 34 people who signed up to run the race. And he tries a big deal because I mean who who who runs from Marath big to devin. The race alternated directions each year and in those early days the press called it a quote
同志马拉松是由一位名叫维克·克拉普姆的白人南非一战老兵发起的。为了纪念在战争中牺牲的战友，他设计了一条连接家乡彼得马里茨堡和约56英里外的沿海城市德班的路线。显然有几个人报了名。我想大约有34人报名参加了比赛。他尝试做一件大事，因为毕竟，谁会从彼得马里茨堡跑到德班呢？比赛每年交替方向，在那些早期，媒体称之为“随心所欲的马拉松”。
marathon go as you please. Guys ran in rugby boots they stopped for a beer and carried chicken at a hotel along the way. This definitely wasn't the first ultra-marathon in the world. Actually, even long before the first modern marathon was held in the 1896 Olympics, a form of super-long-distance racing had been popular in the US and Europe. It was called pedestrianism, and in its heyday in the 1870s and 80s, it was a hugely popular spectator sport,, where competitors racewalked distances up to
伙计们穿着橄榄球靴跑步，他们中途停下来喝啤酒，还带着酒店里的鸡肉。这绝对不是世界上第一场超级马拉松。事实上，甚至在1896年奥运会举办第一场现代马拉松比赛很久之前，一种超长距离赛跑在美国和欧洲就很流行。它被称为“步行运动”（pedestrianism），在19世纪70年代和80年代的全盛时期，它是一项非常受欢迎的观赏性运动，参赛者竞走距离长达
1,500 miles. The sport was so popular that the biggest names earned the equivalent of millions of dollars of prize money. The comrades, on the other hand, was a much more amateur affair. Over the decades, the race grew in size, but not dramatically. By the 1960s, there were maybe 150 guys running it every year, and they were all white. Every once in a while, a woman or a person of color would show up on the start line and run the race unofficially without a number.
1500英里。这项运动非常受欢迎，大牌选手赚取的奖金相当于数百万美元。相比之下，同志马拉松则是一项业余得多的活动。几十年来，比赛规模有所增长，但并不显著。到了20世纪60年代，每年大约有150人参加，而且全是白人。偶尔会有女性或有色人种出现在起跑线上，没有号码地非正式参赛。
The organizers generally didn't pull them off the course, but they never got recorded in the official finish list. In some years, the organizers actually blocked their entry to the stadium where the race ended, so they would never cross the finish line. Between excluding 90% of the population from participating, and then also being, you know, 56 miles long, the comrades seemed doomed to obscurity. But then, the ground started to shift. By the 1970s, apartheid South Africa was one of the last white-ruled countries in Africa, and it was coming under global pressure to change. Anti-apartheid campaigners believed that one of the best ways to force South Africa's
组织者通常不会把他们赶出赛道，但他们从未被记录在正式的完赛名单中。有些年份，组织者甚至会阻止他们进入比赛终点的体育场，所以他们永远无法冲过终点线。在排除了90%的人口参与，再加上56英里的长度，同志马拉松似乎注定要默默无闻。但随后，情况开始发生变化。到了20世纪70年代，种族隔离下的南非是非洲最后一个由白人统治的国家之一，它正面临全球性的变革压力。反种族隔离运动人士认为，迫使南非
hand would be to isolate it from the rest of the world. South African activists organized boycotts of the country's exports. They pressured international companies to divest from the country and urge the world's artists and musicians not to perform there. We are not asking that you make a political decision. We are not asking you to make an economic decision. Archbishop Desmond Tutu, the South African anti-apartite leader. We are asking you to make a moral decision?
让步的最好方法之一就是将其与世界其他地区隔绝。南非活动人士组织了对该国出口产品的抵制。他们向国际公司施压，要求其从该国撤资，并敦促世界各地的艺术家和音乐家不要在那里表演。“我们不是要求你们做出政治决定。我们不是要求你们做出经济决定。”南非反种族隔离领袖德斯蒙德·图图大主教说，“我们是要求你们做出道德决定。”
Those who invest in South Africa for goodness sake must know that they do so, and in doing so are upholding and buttressing one of the most vicious systems the world has ever known. For many South Africans, one of the most painful forms of isolation came in the realm of sports. By the 1970s, the country was no longer allowed to compete in the Olympics or the World Cup.
“那些在南非投资的人，看在上帝的份上，必须知道他们这样做是在支持和巩固世界上最恶毒的制度之一。”对于许多南非人来说，最痛苦的孤立形式之一来自体育领域。到了20世纪70年代，该国不再被允许参加奥运会或世界杯。
They partake government lobbied hard to FIFA to not kick them out, but they were so bizarrely committed to segregation that they pitched some weird, compromised idea of sending an all-white team to the World Cup in 1966, and then an all-black team in 1970. FIFA said no. I don't think you can ever have normal sport in the kind of society we have, a totally abnormal society. Activists understood how this withdrawal from world sports
当时的政府极力游说国际足联不要将他们踢出局，但他们对种族隔离的执着简直到了荒谬的地步，以至于他们提出了一个奇怪的折中方案：在1966年世界杯派出一支全白人球队，然后在1970年派出一支全黑人球队。国际足联拒绝了。“我认为在像我们这样的社会里，永远不可能有正常的体育运动，这是一个完全不正常的社会。”活动人士明白这种退出世界体育舞台
would make the white government feel like pariahs. And it worked. South Africa desperately wanted back into the world's competitions. And so beginning in the early 1970s, it began to experiment with integrating domestic sports. Running was one of the first. In 1974, sports journalist Matsulane Mamabolo's uncle, Titus Mamabolo,
会让白人政府感到自己是贱民。这奏效了。南非迫切希望重返世界比赛。因此，从20世纪70年代初开始，它开始尝试整合国内体育运动。跑步是首批尝试的项目之一。1974年，体育记者马扎拉尼·马马博洛的叔叔提图斯·马马博洛，
became the first black athlete to win an integrated national championship in the five kilometers. And suddenly, Black South Africa started believing that we can compete with white people and even beat them. And I think because of that, the whole country started shifting towards, let's open up to the Black people. The comrades organizers were cornered. They didn't want to be left behind. A year later, in 1975, the organizers opened up the race to people of color. At the time, distance running was enjoying a worldwide boom in popularity.
成为第一位赢得综合全国锦标赛5公里比赛的黑人运动员。突然间，南非黑人开始相信“我们可以与白人竞争，甚至击败他们”。“我认为正因为如此，整个国家开始转向：让我们向黑人开放吧。”同志马拉松的组织者被逼到了墙角。他们不想被抛在后面。一年后，即1975年，组织者向有色人种开放了比赛。当时，长跑运动正在全球范围内蓬勃发展。
It was also beginning to include more and more women. For a long time, the conventional wisdom held that women couldn't run marathons because it would damage their delicate reproductive organs. But by the 1970s, prohibitions on female runners were also starting to fall. The comrades dropped its ban on women the same year as it became multiracial. All these circumstances helped running become more popular in South Africa, too. Still, the comrades might have languished forever and of security if it weren't for one more factor. In 1976, South Africa became one of the last major economies in the world to get television,
它也开始接纳越来越多的女性。长期以来，传统观念认为女性不能跑马拉松，因为这会损害她们娇弱的生殖器官。但到了20世纪70年代，对女性跑者的禁令也开始瓦解。同志马拉松在实现种族融合的同一年取消了对女性的禁令。所有这些情况也促使跑步在南非变得更加流行。尽管如此，如果不是因为另一个因素，同志马拉松可能永远会在默默无闻中消亡。1976年，南非成为世界上最后一个拥有电视的主要经济体之一，
when it began broadcasting a single state-run channel. For nearly a decade, many of the country's leaders had resisted the introduction of TV because they believed it could indoctrinate South Africans with dangerous ideas. The country's minister for posts and telegraphs called it the devil's own box for disseminating communism and immorality.
当时它开始播放唯一的国营频道。近十年来，该国的许多领导人一直抵制电视的引入，因为他们认为电视会向南非人灌输危险的思想。该国邮电部长称其为“传播共产主义和不道德行为的魔鬼盒子”。
Already we can see how easy it is to create and instill wrong impressions about peoples and countries by slanted news and pictures and unbalanced presentation of facts. This is South African Prime Minister BJ Forster, giving his first televised address about television. But even as it was trying to stop South Africans from seeing too much of the world, that TV channel had a lot of space to fill, and so it started playing a lot of local sports. Beginning in the 1980s, the SAPC began to broadcast the Comrades' Live in its full,
“我们已经可以看到，通过歪曲的新闻和图片以及不平衡的事实呈现，制造和灌输关于人民和国家的错误印象是多么容易。”这是南非总理B.J.福斯特首次就电视问题发表电视讲话。但即使在试图阻止南非人看到太多外部世界的同时，那个电视频道也有很多空间需要填补，于是它开始播放大量的本地体育节目。从20世纪80年代开始，南非广播公司（SABC）开始全程直播同志马拉松，
tedious entirety, for the whole country to see. For a new station with a lot of time to fill, a race that took literally all day was actually perfect. And what South African saw when they tuned in felt to many like a revolution. They're on their way. South African runners, greatest challenge of human endurance. In a country where almost everything was segregated,
枯燥乏味地完整呈现，让全国人民观看。对于一个有很多时间需要填补的新电视台来说，一场真正耗时一整天的比赛实际上是完美的。当南非人收看节目时，他们所看到的对许多人来说就像一场革命。“他们上路了。南非跑者，人类耐力的最大挑战。”在一个几乎所有事物都被隔离的国家，
from neighborhoods and schools, down to park benches and beaches, the comrades was mixed. What we are witnessing is an almost nakedly explicit presentation of the greatest race of all, the marathon of life itself. For Black South Africans who watched the race in that era, the comrades wasn't just a stunning athletic feat.
从社区和学校，到公园长椅和海滩，同志马拉松却是混合的。“我们所目睹的是对最伟大比赛——生命马拉松本身——近乎赤裸裸的明确呈现。”对于那个时代观看比赛的南非黑人来说，同志马拉松不仅仅是一项惊人的体育壮举。
It looked in many ways like a parallel universe. When you're watching comrades, you see this spectacle that is abnormal actually. You see a white guy running with a black guy even hiding him, like, oh, you can touch a white man. You know, they're sharing their interests. It was aspirational. It was, oh, this is what our country should be like. In the years after the race integrated, most of the runners were still white, but at every level, black runners were making quick inroads. From the weekend, warriors finishing the
它在许多方面看起来像是一个平行宇宙。“当你观看同志马拉松时，你看到的这种景象实际上是不正常的。你看到一个白人跑者和一个黑人跑者在一起，甚至在帮助他，就像，哦，你可以触碰一个白人。你知道，他们在分享共同的兴趣。这是一种向往。这是一种‘哦，我们的国家应该就是这样’的感觉。”在比赛实现融合后的几年里，大多数跑者仍然是白人，但在各个层面上，黑人跑者都在迅速取得进展。从周末
race in 11 hours up to the elites running it in less than six Around the time the race integrated Hosea Charlie was working as a gardener for a white family in the northern suburbs of Johannesburg During the day he planted flowers and clipped hedges and then it mattered much greener kitchen to help wash the dishes. As you were the gardener during the day and the at night you were the dishes. And in between, sometimes, he went for a jog. I just had a time as that to run for fun. Pretty soon, he realized he was really fast, and the longer the distance, the better. He started running marathons, and then he decided to go bigger.
战士们在11小时内完成比赛，到精英选手在不到6小时内跑完。在比赛融合前后，何塞·查理在约翰内斯堡北部郊区的一户白人家里做园丁。白天他种花修剪树篱，然后回到绿色的厨房帮忙洗碗。“白天你是园丁，晚上你是洗碗工。”而在中间，有时他会去慢跑。“我只是有时间去跑步玩玩。”很快，他意识到自己跑得非常快，而且距离越长，表现越好。他开始跑马拉松，然后决定挑战更长的距离。
Just in the river, there's a comrades. What is a comrades? It's a death and tomorrow's back. I don't know what that death looks like. I don't know what that death and tomorrow's back looks like. In 1979, Josea ran his first comrades and finished 21st of nearly 3,000 runners. He started to think, hey, maybe I could win this thing someday.
“就在河边，有同志马拉松。什么是同志马拉松？那是‘死亡与明天的回归’。我不知道那死亡看起来是什么样。我不知道那‘死亡与明天的回归’看起来是什么样。”1979年，何塞参加了他的第一次同志马拉松，在近3000名跑者中获得第21名。他开始想，嘿，也许有一天我能赢得这场比赛。
At that point, the comrades had never had a black winner, but soon, Hosea became one of the race's favorites. He ran with a distinctive, lopsided gate and almost always raced in a floppy blue and white bucket hat. Fans, particularly in black areas, along the comrades' route, would pour into the road as he ran by cheering him along. It didn't just make us believe
那时，同志马拉松还从未有过黑人冠军，但很快，何塞就成了比赛的热门选手。他跑步时姿势独特，身体倾斜，而且几乎总是戴着一顶松垮的蓝白相间渔夫帽。粉丝们，特别是在同志马拉松路线沿途的黑人聚居区，会在他跑过时涌入路边为他欢呼。这不仅让我们相信
that we could be good in just sports, in just about every field you started thinking, oh, no, white people are not that great. I can be better in this, I can be better, and it gave hope. In those years, Hosea was racing to beat a white archaeology student named Bruce Fordes. Two men are out in front, one is Ebony and one is white. Maybe that's why they call this classic race the comrades.
我们不仅在体育方面可以表现出色，在几乎所有领域，你开始想，哦，不，白人并没有那么了不起。我可以在这方面做得更好，我可以做得更好，这给了我们希望。那些年，何塞正在与一位名叫布鲁斯·福迪斯的白人考古学学生竞争。“两名男子在前面，一个是黑人，一个是白人。也许这就是为什么他们把这场经典比赛称为‘同志马拉松’。”
And in South Africa, what a refreshing side it is to see a black man and a white man striving side by side in search of victory. It was almost a tale of South Africa really. You know, it told us, here was this black guy and this white guy, they became rivals and in the country I can bet you we all supported them along racial lines. But the hierarchies of apartheid were hard to outrun. Throughout the 80s, Bruce Fordi's trained full time
“在南非，看到一个黑人和一个白人并肩努力追求胜利，是多么令人耳目一新的景象。”这几乎就是南非的真实写照。你知道，它告诉我们，这里有这个黑人伙计和这个白人伙计，他们成了竞争对手，而在那个国家，我敢打赌我们都沿着种族界限支持他们。但种族隔离的等级制度很难摆脱。整个80年代，布鲁斯·福迪斯全职训练
with the comrades and other altress, living off speaking gigs and sponsorships. Jose got his training by running 15 miles to his job as a delivery driver and competing in races at any distance from six miles up to 60 every weekend. I don't know, did you ever feel angry that he had more resources? Because he was a white person. It's that luck. That lucky.
参加同志马拉松和其他超级马拉松，靠演讲和赞助为生。何塞的训练方式是每天跑15英里去送货员的工作岗位，并且每个周末参加从6英里到60英里不等的比赛。“我不知道，你有没有因为他拥有更多资源而感到愤怒？因为他是白人？”“那是运气。那个幸运的
white person. It's their luck. They are lucky. But even on this very uneven playing field, long distance running was a life-changing experience for many runners of color. Everybody's feeling the same pain, the aches and pains, they're all feeling the same thing as you feeling. You know, if a guy's struggling and you're happy my longing, because you know the pain he guy is struggling, you have been alone, because you know the pain he's going through, and you can identify what it is. That's Pubi Nidu, a runner of Indian heritage who also raised the comrades in the Sierra. At his peak, he could finish the race in a little more than six hours, which meant averaging
白人。那是他们的运气。他们很幸运。”但即使在这个非常不平等的竞争环境中，长跑对许多有色人种跑者来说也是一种改变人生的经历。“每个人都感受着同样的痛苦，酸痛和疼痛，他们感受到的和你感受到的一模一样。你知道，如果一个人在挣扎，而你正在超越他，因为你知道他正在经历的痛苦，你可以感同身受。”那是普比·尼杜，一位同样在那个年代参加同志马拉松的印度裔跑者。在他巅峰时期，他能在6小时多一点的时间内完成比赛，这意味着平均
just over a six and a half minute mile for 56 miles. As soon as the comrades at Gangos off, there's no quality of human, there's no segregation, there's nothing to do with color. Everybody's out there to run the base to prove that they can't finish the race and that type. And so everybody's sort of like the lawyers and doctors and all this, all come down to your level now.
每英里配速略高于6分半钟，全程56英里。“一旦同志马拉松开始，就没有人类的等级之分，没有种族隔离，与肤色无关。每个人都在那里奔跑，证明他们能完成比赛。所以每个人，律师、医生等等，现在都降到了同一个水平。”
So the playing feels like equal. But if for those 56 miles there was no apartheid, as soon as athletes stepped off the course, it was back to normal life in South Africa. After Congress is back to the same black and white. In other words, you've got to know your place. You're black and you stay black. Hosea left his running club in the early 80s
所以竞争环境看起来是平等的。但如果在那56英里内没有种族隔离，一旦运动员离开赛道，南非的生活就恢复了正常。“同志马拉松结束后，又回到了同样的黑白分明。换句话说，你必须知道自己的位置。你是黑人，你就保持黑人身份。”何塞在80年代初离开了他的跑步俱乐部，
after the chairperson allegedly called him by a racial slur. And he might have been allowed in white areas while he was running a marathon. But the rest of the time, he could be arrested if he didn't have the correct stamps in his past book. That's a document black people had to carry to show they had permission to be in a white neighborhood.
据称是因为主席用种族歧视的语言称呼他。虽然他在跑马拉松时可能被允许进入白人区域，但在其他时间，如果他的通行证上没有正确的印章，他可能会被逮捕。那是黑人必须随身携带的文件，以证明他们有权进入白人社区。
He told me about a time this happened to him outside a train station in Johannesburg when he was on his way to work. In the station when he came in the train, we come out in a platform and street the police tried me. Heidi, you're not allowed to come here working in a traffic.
他告诉我一次这发生在他约翰内斯堡火车站外的情况，当时他正要去上班。“在车站，当我下火车来到站台时，警察拦住了我。‘嘿，你不准来这里工作。’”
So what did you do? Well, I got to do, to the gym and jeep. But the late 1980s apartheid was on its last legs. South Africa was in the grips of a low grade civil war. The government was cracking down violently on protests. Black areas of cities were patroled by soldiers. Abductions, torture, and beatings of activists were common.
“那你做了什么？”“我只能去……去健身房。”但到了20世纪80年代末，种族隔离制度已是强弩之末。南非陷入了一场低强度的内战。政府暴力镇压抗议活动。城市的黑人区有士兵巡逻。绑架、酷刑和殴打活动人士的情况屡见不鲜。
A part aid is a criminal act against the empire. That's Winnie Mandela, the anti-apartite activist and wife of Nelson Mandela, who by the mid-1980s had been in prison for more than 20 years. In this world, the comments began to take on a kind of outsized symbolic meaning. For several years in a row, it had seemed like Hosea was on the brink of winning the race, but every year, in the final miles, Bruce Fordis would surge from behind and win. Then, in 1989, Bruce and Hosea both competed in a 62-mile race shortly before the comrades. As a result, Bruce decided not to compete in the comrades at all,
“种族隔离是对人类的犯罪行为。”那是温妮·曼德拉，反种族隔离活动家，也是纳尔逊·曼德拉的妻子，曼德拉到80年代中期已经在监狱里关了20多年。在这个世界里，同志马拉松开始具有一种超乎寻常的象征意义。连续几年，何塞似乎都处于赢得比赛的边缘，但每年在最后几英里，布鲁斯·福迪斯都会从后面冲上来获胜。然后，在1989年，布鲁斯和何塞在同志马拉松前不久都参加了一场62英里的比赛。结果，布鲁斯决定根本不参加同志马拉松，
and Hosea raced it on tired legs. That blew the field wide open. Good morning, nice to have you with us. It's 545, and we are counting down to the start of the world's greatest long-distance road race, the comrades. On the morning of May 31, 1989, the elite runners eyed each other nervously. After all, Bruce was the only man who had won the race since 1981. What else could a comrades champion look like? That morning several runners pulled out in front, but for a long time, no one could break away. But in the final 10 miles, two runners surged ahead. Both of them gritting their teeth, determined no smiles for the crowd, slugging it out toe-to-toe
而何塞拖着疲惫的双腿参赛。这让比赛结果变得扑朔迷离。“早上好，很高兴有你们陪伴。现在是5点45分，我们正在倒计时迎接世界上最伟大的长距离公路赛——同志马拉松。”1989年5月31日清晨，精英跑者们紧张地注视着彼此。毕竟，布鲁斯是自1981年以来唯一赢得比赛的人。同志马拉松冠军还能是什么样？那天早上，几名跑者冲在前面，但很长一段时间里，没有人能突围。但在最后10英里，两名跑者冲到了前面。他们都咬紧牙关，神情坚毅，没有对人群微笑，并肩作战，
like two boxes in the ring. For the first time in the closing miles of a Comrades, both of the leaders were black. One of them, William Tolo, had been among the favorites, but as the race approached the finish in Durban, he suddenly slowed down, grimacing in pain. That left only a relatively unknown runner named Samuel Shabbalala. He was a railway worker from a small farming town, who often trained by running the 30 miles home from his job in his work. For the first time in more than 65 years, the comrades had a black winner.
就像拳击台上的两名拳手。在同志马拉松的最后几英里，两名领先者首次都是黑人。其中一人，威廉·托洛，曾是夺冠热门之一，但当比赛接近德班终点时，他突然慢了下来，痛苦地皱着眉头。这只剩下了一位相对不知名的跑者，名叫塞缪尔·沙巴拉拉。他是一名来自小农镇的铁路工人，经常通过从工作地点跑30英里回家来训练。在超过65年以来，同志马拉松首次有了黑人冠军。
He has this first black man to win the conference and he then added to what Horsia had done isn't it? Yes, we believed he can compete, yes, but now we believe he can win. Eight months later, South African President F.W. Declorek delivered news that would change the course of the entire country's future. For decades, anti-apartheid activists had been relentlessly harassed, intimidated, and imprisoned. Now, suddenly, the government was unbanging them. The prohibition of the African National Congress, the Pan-Africanist Congress, the South African Communist Party, and a number of subsidiary organizations
“他是第一个赢得同志马拉松的黑人，他延续了何塞所做的一切，不是吗？”“是的，我们相信他能竞争，是的，但现在我们相信他能赢。”八个月后，南非总统F.W.德克勒克发布了将改变整个国家未来进程的消息。几十年来，反种族隔离活动人士一直受到无情的骚扰、恐吓和监禁。现在，政府突然解除了对他们的禁令。“对非洲人国民大会、泛非主义者大会、南非共产党以及一些附属组织的禁令
is being resented. I wish to put it plainly organizations is being rescinded. I wish to put it plainly that the government has taken a firm decision to release Mr. Mandela unconditional. So you have same winning and then following him Mandela comes out of jail and just black people we all just start thinking we own the country now. Everything is ours. Four years later, in April 1994, South Africa held its first democratic election. Nelson Mandela became president. We're the people of South Africa.
正在被撤销。我想明确指出，政府已做出坚定决定，无条件释放曼德拉先生。”“所以你有塞缪尔获胜，然后紧接着曼德拉出狱，我们黑人开始觉得我们现在拥有这个国家了。一切都是我们的。”四年后，1994年4月，南非举行了首次民主选举。纳尔逊·曼德拉当选总统。“我们是南非人民。”
Feel fulfilled that humanity has taken us back into its bosom. That way, we were outlaws, not so long ago, had today given the rare privilege to be hosted to the nations of the world on our own soil. Mandela had always been big into sports throughout his life. He was a boxer and also a regular runner. And that wouldn't be remarkable except that he did all of his jogging for more than two decades inside of an 8x7 foot prison cell. Running taught me valuable lessons. He wrote in his autobiography, Long Walk to Freedom. Training counted more than intrinsic ability, and I could compensate for a lack of natural
“感到满足的是，人类已经把我们重新接纳到它的怀抱中。不久前我们还是不法之徒，今天却获得了罕见的特权，在我们的土地上接待世界各国。”曼德拉一生都非常热爱体育。他是一名拳击手，也是一名经常跑步的人。如果不是因为他在超过二十年的时间里，所有的慢跑都是在8x7英尺的牢房里进行的，那这并不值得一提。“跑步教会了我宝贵的经验。”他在自传《漫漫自由路》中写道，“训练比天赋更重要，我可以用勤奋和纪律来弥补天生
aptitude with diligence and discipline. I applied this in everything I did. So it felt symbolic when, in 1996, Nelson Mandela came to the comrades to present the winners their trophies. After we've listened, what happened today? And especially after seeing the current and determination of those who just made it, I have decided to take part in the next public marathon.
能力的不足。我把我所做的一切都应用到了这一点上。”因此，当1996年纳尔逊·曼德拉来到同志马拉松现场为获胜者颁奖时，这感觉具有象征意义。“听了今天发生的事情，特别是看到那些刚刚完成比赛的人的毅力和决心，我决定参加下一届同志马拉松。”
To be clear, he was joking, even if you're Nelson Mandela, running 56 miles when you're 78 is a big ask. But his presence at the race underscored that it had become a South African institution, and throughout the 1990s and early 2000s, its popularity continued to grow, drawing more and more new runners. Runners like future comrades-pacer, Shihida Tango. So you would watch comrades from start start to finish and the whole day. When she was growing up in a black township south of Johannesburg in the 1980s,
说清楚，他是在开玩笑，即使你是纳尔逊·曼德拉，在78岁时跑56英里也是一个巨大的挑战。但他在比赛中的出现强调了它已经成为南非的一种制度，在整个90年代和21世纪初，它的受欢迎程度持续增长，吸引了越来越多的新跑者。像未来的同志马拉松配速员沙希达·通戈这样的跑者。“所以你会从头到尾观看同志马拉松，整整一天。”当她在20世纪80年代在约翰内斯堡南部的黑人城镇长大时，
her family always watched the race. And that's what I knew about Conrad's. And I knew it's very long. I knew it's very painful because I saw what Tranas looked like they had to finish. And I knew I would never do that thing. That's what I knew about Conrad. Then in 2011, when Shehita was in her mid-30s and working at a bank in Johannesburg, her life was ripped up by its roots.
她的家人总是观看比赛。“这就是我所知道的同志马拉松。我知道它非常长。我知道它非常痛苦，因为我看到了跑者完赛时的样子。我知道我永远不会做那种事。这就是我所知道的同志马拉松。”然后，在2011年，当沙希达30多岁并在约翰内斯堡的一家银行工作时，她的生活被彻底颠覆了。
I was actually diagnosed with the form of skin cancer and it was a week after that my husband passed away and I just started walking and then I started jogging and then the jogging came into running and I went for my first 10 kilometers and it clubbed me good and proper and I love the feeling at the end. Soon she was racing longer and longer distances. She never ran fast but she found she had nearly endless endurance. And as she went along, she'd chant and sing to herself to distract her from the pain of running. Other runners started to join her, and pretty soon, race organizers began to ask her to
“我被诊断出患有一种皮肤癌，就在那之后一周，我丈夫去世了，我开始走路，然后开始慢跑，然后慢跑变成了跑步，我参加了我的第一次10公里比赛，它让我彻底折服，我喜欢终点的那种感觉。”很快，她参加了越来越长的比赛。她跑得不快，但她发现自己有近乎无穷的耐力。在跑步过程中，她会对自己吟唱和唱歌，以分散自己对跑步痛苦的注意力。其他跑者开始加入她，很快，赛事组织者开始要求她
be an official pace. This isn't a small job. Imagine that not only do you have to commit to running a 56-mile race, but you must also promise to finish it in a very specific time. They wanted her to pace to finish in 12 hours. 12 hours is the official cutoff time for the race. That meant that she had absolutely no margin for error. If she ran slower than she expected, her bus wouldn't just finish late.
担任官方配速员。这不是一份轻松的工作。想象一下，你不仅要承诺跑完56英里的比赛，还必须保证在非常具体的时间内完成。他们希望她带领跑者在12小时内完赛。12小时是比赛的官方关门时间。这意味着她绝对没有任何犯错的余地。如果她跑得比预期的慢，她的“公交车”不仅会迟到，
Those runners would be blocked from crossing the finish line at all. At the time, Shaheeda had only run the Comreds once, but she loved pacing slow runners, because sure, if you pace faster runners, you might help them break a personal record or something. But if you pace the slowest runners, you might be the difference that helps them achieve this nearly impossible thing.
那些跑者甚至会被禁止冲过终点线。当时，沙希达只跑过一次同志马拉松，但她喜欢带领慢速跑者，因为当然，如果你带领快速跑者，你可能会帮助他们打破个人纪录什么的。但如果你带领最慢的跑者，你可能会成为帮助他们实现这一近乎不可能之事的关键。
I become a comedian on the day, I become a mother, I become a psychologist. I find runners that are going through the most. And I'll tell them, we all feel like you. If you think you are the only one in pain, you are not. You know, put on your big go, bloomers, come let's go. Just take two steps. She's paced the 12-hour bus ever since.
“那天我成了喜剧演员，成了母亲，成了心理学家。我找到那些正在经历最痛苦时刻的跑者。我会告诉他们，我们都有同感。如果你认为你是唯一感到痛苦的人，那你就错了。你知道，穿上你的大裤衩，来吧，我们走。只要迈出两步。”从那以后，她一直担任12小时配速员。
And this year, after two years off because of COVID, the race was back, and so was Shihita. So, ladies and gentlemen, welcome to your day, stay high, you freebie! After the gun fires, I watched the runners streaming over the start line. It takes more than 10 minutes before I finally see Shaheeda, jogging slowly just in front of the ambulance that follows the slowest runners in case of medical emergencies. I see her again about seven miles later, in a little farming town called Ashburton. At this point, the 12-hour bus is still tiny. She has maybe a dozen people running with her, and they're all looking suspiciously cheerful.
今年，在因新冠疫情停办两年后，比赛回归了，沙希达也回来了。“女士们先生们，欢迎来到你们的日子，保持高昂，你们是自由的！”发令枪响后，我看着跑者们涌过起跑线。过了10多分钟，我才终于看到沙希达，在跟随最慢跑者的救护车前缓慢慢跑，以防医疗紧急情况。大约7英里后，我在一个叫阿什伯顿的小农镇再次见到她。此时，12小时“公交车”仍然很小。她身边大约有十几个人在跑，他们看起来都出奇地开朗。
Before the comrades this year, I spoke to a runner who'd finished it 41 times. He told me that what appeals to him about running a 56-mile race over and over and over is that it's like living your entire life in one day. The experience holds the entire range of human emotion from elation to despair, and gathered all along the course are thousands and thousands of spectators, singing, cheering, and encouraging the runners on.
在今年的同志马拉松之前，我采访了一位已经41次完赛的跑者。他告诉我，他之所以喜欢一遍又一遍地跑56英里的比赛，是因为这就像在一天之内过完你的一生。这种体验包含了从狂喜到绝望的整个人类情感范围，沿途聚集了成千上万的观众，唱歌、欢呼，鼓励跑者前进。
Good for singing, ladies and most of them! Woo! Hi, guys! By the time I see Shaheeda again, we are more than 35 miles into the race, in a Durban suburb called Pine Town. Her bus has swelled to about 50 people. There's this super-dazed look in her eyes, and she seems a bit wobbly, but she's still cheerful. How you doing? How you feeling?
“唱得好，女士们，你们大多数人！呜！嘿，伙计们！”当我再次见到沙希达时，我们已经跑了35英里多，在德班郊区的一个叫派恩镇的地方。她的“公交车”已经扩大到大约50人。她的眼神里有一种超级恍惚的神情，看起来有点摇晃，但她依然开朗。“你怎么样？感觉如何？”
Amazing. How you doing? How you feeling? And then a couple hours later, I'm waiting for her at the finish inside Moses Amazing! And then a couple hours later, I'm waiting for her at the finish inside Moses Mbita, a World Cup stadium in Durban. The clock is ticking down. There's 30 minutes left, then 10. Still no sign of Sheheda. Suddenly, I hear it. It's a bunch of shots of our side-hours. I can't get through to the one-point, so we can't let our eyes see the stars.
“太棒了。你怎么样？感觉如何？”几个小时后，我在德班的摩西·马比达世界杯体育场终点线等她。时钟在倒计时。还剩30分钟，然后是10分钟。仍然没有沙希达的踪影。突然，我听到了。那是我们这边的一阵欢呼声。“我无法到达那个点，所以我们无法让我们的眼睛看到星星。”
Now, there is a huge pack of runners behind Shaheeda, this tidal wave of bright-colored running jerseys. And in the middle of it all, I see her little pacer flag with a big 12-written on it, bobbing up and down. You tell all the pains like this, and you can come after the finish line is fine. And we're just going to dance, and we're going to shut comrades down. And that's what we did when we hit the grass aden. The eat was just amazing, you know.
现在，沙希达身后有一大群跑者，这是一股色彩鲜艳的跑步衫潮汐。在这一切中间，我看到了她那面写着大大的“12”的小配速旗，上下晃动。“你告诉所有的痛苦就像这样，你可以冲过终点线，没问题。我们只是要跳舞，我们要结束同志马拉松。”当我们踏上草地时，我们就是这么做的。那种感觉真是太棒了，你知道。
The stadium became alive. The clock reads 11 hours 53 minutes as she jogs over the finish line and bursts into tears. We cross the finish line and it was so emotional, the hugs, the guys were like, I could get it if they could love me up, they probably would have even a once. It's so his we were. Meanwhile, hundreds of people are still streaming over the finish line as the stadium speakers begin to play final countdown. All at once, a line of Comrade staff swarms across the whole finish line, blocking anyone still on the course from finishing.
体育场变得活跃起来。当她慢跑冲过终点线时，时钟显示11小时53分钟，她泪流满面。“我们冲过终点线，太感人了，那些拥抱，伙计们就像，如果他们能拥抱我，他们可能会拥抱一次。我们就是这样。”与此同时，当体育场扬声器开始播放《最后的倒计时》时，数百人仍在涌过终点线。突然间，一排同志马拉松工作人员蜂拥而至，封锁了整个终点线，阻止任何仍在赛道上的人完赛。
Dazed, exhausted runners keep slamming into it. I hate this part. Seeing all these people who have been running for 12 hours not finish, they look shattered. But watching them also reminds me why Shahidah's 12 hour bus is so powerful. All those people could easily have not finished too, but somehow they did it. Convex is painful. You are really going to hurt on the road. You're going to lose your mind while running. But if you do it with someone or some people, it makes it not so mammoth. There's a story that sports psychologists like to tell about Roger Bannister, the Oxford University Medical student who first broke the four-minute mile in 1954.
恍惚、疲惫的跑者不断撞向它。“我讨厌这一部分。看到所有这些跑了12小时的人没能完赛，他们看起来心碎了。但看着他们也提醒了我为什么沙希达的12小时‘公交车’如此强大。所有那些人本来也很容易没能完赛，但不知何故他们做到了。”“同志马拉松很痛苦。你在路上真的会受伤。你在跑步时会失去理智。但如果你和某人或某些人一起做，它就不会那么庞大。”关于罗杰·班尼斯特，这位1954年首次打破4分钟英里纪录的牛津大学医学生，体育心理学家喜欢讲一个故事。
Until then, four minutes seemed like an almost superhuman barrier. People had been trying and failing to break it for nearly 70 years. But once Roger Bannister ran a sub-four-minute mile, four more people did it in the next year. Now more than 1,600 people have run a mile and under four minutes. The barrier, it turned out, was largely psychological. Shahida and the 12-hour bus feel like a comrades equivalent of that. Watching them pour over the finish line, the race feels doable.
在那之前，4分钟似乎是一个近乎超人的障碍。人们尝试了近70年都未能打破它。但一旦罗杰·班尼斯特跑进了4分钟，第二年又有4个人做到了。现在已经有超过1600人跑进了4分钟。事实证明，这个障碍在很大程度上是心理上的。沙希达和12小时“公交车”感觉就像同志马拉松版的那个障碍。看着他们涌过终点线，比赛感觉是可以做到的。
Running 56 miles feels like a thing that anyone can achieve. At least, it is in South Africa. Coming up after the break, we talk about one of the most famous South African sports stories ever and how it connects to post-apartheid South African politics. We're back with Ryan Lenora Brown, who reported this week's story, to talk a little more about sports and politics in South Africa. Yeah, and what I want to talk about in particular is the sport that most Americans know very little about, but that's really, really popular in South Africa and has played actually a big role in the country's recent history. Rugby.
跑56英里感觉像是任何人都能实现的事情。至少在南非是这样。休息后回来，我们将讨论南非历史上最著名的体育故事之一，以及它如何与后种族隔离时代的南非政治联系起来。我们回到了报道本周故事的瑞安·莱诺拉·布朗身边，进一步讨论南非的体育和政治。“是的，我想特别谈谈大多数美国人知之甚少，但在南非非常、非常流行，并且在国家近期历史中发挥了巨大作用的运动。橄榄球。”
Well, I know about rugby. I know rugby exists. You are right, though. It is not very popular here in the US. Yeah, so maybe the easiest place to start here is with a rugby reference Americans might be familiar with. Have you ever seen the film Invictus? Uh, I'm aware of its existence, but I have not seen it, no. Okay, so it's this Clint Eastwood movie starring Morgan Freeman as Nelson Mandela with an honestly slightly questionable South African accent. The only friends why, how do we inspire ourselves to greatness when nothing less will do?
嗯，我知道橄榄球。我知道橄榄球的存在。不过你说得对，它在美国确实不太受欢迎。所以，也许最简单的切入点是引用一个美国人可能熟悉的橄榄球例子。你看过电影《成事在人》（Invictus）吗？呃，我知道有这部电影，但我没看过。好吧，那是克林特·伊斯特伍德执导的电影，摩根·弗里曼饰演纳尔逊·曼德拉，他的南非口音说实话有点令人质疑。唯一的朋友，为什么，当没有其他选择时，我们如何激励自己去追求伟大？
How do we inspire everyone around us? Yeah. But anyway, Invictus is the story of South Africa's unexpected victory in the 1995 Rugby World Cup. Okay, so what was significant about that? Well, for one thing, it was a kind of masterclass in Mandela's ability to make these big, sweeping symbolic gestures of unity, which he did a lot in those years. Yeah, I mean, I can imagine he had to, because he had recently become president in the country
我们如何激励周围的每一个人？是的。但不管怎样，《成事在人》讲述的是南非在1995年橄榄球世界杯上出人意料夺冠的故事。那么，这有什么意义呢？嗯，首先，这堪称曼德拉展现其团结象征性姿态的大师级手笔，他在那些年里经常这样做。是的，我的意思是，我可以想象他必须这样做，因为他刚成为这个国家的总统，
that was incredibly divided and deeply segregated, and he became president after 27 years in prison. So there's a lot to heal there. Right. And that actually included sports. So, you know, we just talked in this episode about how long distance running became the sport that transcended all these divides. But by the 1990s, most sports in South Africa were still seen as kind of quote unquote,
这个国家曾经极其分裂且种族隔离严重，他在入狱27年后当选总统。所以有很多创伤需要治愈。没错。这实际上也包括体育。所以，你知道，我们刚才在这一集中谈到了长跑是如何成为超越所有这些分歧的运动的。但到了20世纪90年代，南非的大多数运动仍然被视为所谓的，
belonging to certain races. Obviously, I don't mean people of other races didn't play those sports, just that they were very strongly, culturally associated with particular groups. So for instance, soccer was a quote, black sport, cricket was a quote, white sport. And where did rugby fall in this divide? There've always been black rugby leagues in teams in South Africa, but rugby was widely seen as a white sport. So to get back to the rugby world cup in 1995,
属于特定的种族。显然，我并不是说其他种族的人不参与这些运动，只是它们在文化上与特定群体有着非常强烈的联系。例如，足球被称为“黑人运动”，板球被称为“白人运动”。那么橄榄球在这个分歧中处于什么位置呢？南非一直有黑人橄榄球联盟和球队，但橄榄球被广泛视为一项白人运动。所以回到1995年的橄榄球世界杯，
this is the biggest tournament for the sport, teams from all over the world compete with each other. And that year South Africa hosted the tournament, which was significant because it was also the first time that South Africa was allowed to play since apartheid had ended. But the team it fielded was almost entirely white, and so were the supporters. And actually it was like even worse than that.
这是该项运动最大的赛事，来自世界各地的球队相互竞争。那一年南非主办了锦标赛，这意义重大，因为这是南非自种族隔离制度结束以来首次被允许参赛。但它派出的球队几乎全是白人，支持者也是如此。实际上情况甚至更糟。
A lot of Black South Africans were rugby fans, but they would cheer for whoever was playing against South Africa, particularly New Zealand. They saw the Spring Box who are South Africa's national team as actually a symbol of white supremacy. So what did Mandela do here? Well, first he approached the Spring Box captain, who was this white guy named Francois Pinar,
许多南非黑人是橄榄球迷，但他们会为任何与南非对阵的球队加油，尤其是新西兰队。他们将南非国家队“跳羚队”（Springboks）视为白人至上的象征。那么曼德拉在这里做了什么？嗯，首先他接触了跳羚队的队长，一个叫弗朗索瓦·皮纳尔的白人，
and basically asked him to make the point to the team, to the public, that they represented the new South Africa. Do you hear? Listen to your country. This is it. This is our destiny. Oh, fuck out, dude.
并基本上要求他向球队和公众传达一个观点，即他们代表了新的南非。你听到了吗？听听你的国家。就是这样。这就是我们的命运。哦，去你的，伙计。
That's another clip from Invictus, and I was met Damon, by the way, doing actually a pretty good Afrocon's accent. Anyway, the rest of what Mandela did was pretty simple. He went to the games, he wore the team's jersey, and he cheered for them like they were his team. When they won the whole thing in this nail-biter game in downtown Joeburg against New Zealand, he presented them with their trophy. There it is.
那是《成事在人》的另一个片段，顺便说一下，马特·达蒙的南非口音其实模仿得相当不错。总之，曼德拉所做的其余事情很简单。他去看了比赛，穿上了球队的球衣，像支持自己的球队一样为他们加油。当他们在约翰内斯堡市中心那场对阵新西兰的紧张比赛中获胜时，他为他们颁发了奖杯。就是这样。
Francois Pina, Nelson Mandela, is cheering along with the whole of the stadium. See her flags. Wonderful moment for the whole of South Africa. This footage is actually really sweet. You can see Mandela pumping his arms and genuinely looking very jazzed about the team winning. And so what happened after that? What was the result of all this unity
弗朗索瓦·皮纳尔，纳尔逊·曼德拉，正与整个体育场的人一起欢呼。看她的旗帜。对整个南非来说都是美妙的时刻。这段录像真的很温馨。你可以看到曼德拉挥舞着双臂，看起来对球队的胜利感到非常兴奋。那么在那之后发生了什么？所有这些团结的成果是什么？
at the rugby world cup? Well, obviously South Africa didn't change overnight. Neither did the rugby team. The gesture was really significant to a lot of people, but it took also actual policies to make really significant changes happen. And what that looked like is that in the late 1990s, the government started creating these racial quotas for sports teams to get them to transform.
在橄榄球世界杯上？嗯，显然南非并没有在一夜之间改变。橄榄球队也没有。这个姿态对很多人来说确实意义重大，但要实现真正的重大变革还需要实际的政策。这就是在20世纪90年代末，政府开始为体育队制定种族配额，以促使他们进行转型。
Those quotas have been really controversial. And so that goes, you can imagine. Yeah, I can imagine those are controversial, but to eventually they just become part of everyone's life and therefore it not necessary anymore. I would say yes and no, you know, a lot of people would argue that these kind of transformations really have to start at the level of youths for club sports to be meaningful to not tokenize black players, not put them forward when they're not ready. And you've seen that start to happen. And in rugby in particular, rugby is sort of one of the leaders among South African sports. But in any case, the South African rugby team now does look really different
这些配额一直非常有争议。所以，你可以想象。是的，我可以想象这些是有争议的，但最终它们成为了每个人生活的一部分，因此不再必要了。我会说既是也不是，你知道，很多人会争辩说，这种转型必须从青少年俱乐部体育层面开始，才有意义，而不是为了象征性地展示黑人球员，在他们还没准备好时就推上去。你已经看到这种情况开始发生了。特别是在橄榄球方面，橄榄球在南非体育界算是领头羊之一。但无论如何，现在的南非橄榄球队看起来确实与1995年时大不相同了。
than it did back in 1995. So what's it like now? Well, to answer that question, we're actually gonna go quickly to another rugby world cup. This one's in Japan in 2019 and spoiler alert. South Africa actually won again. The biggest prize of the world! South Africa!
那么现在是什么样子呢？嗯，为了回答这个问题，我们实际上要快速转到另一届橄榄球世界杯。这是2019年在日本举行的那一届，剧透预警。南非实际上又赢了。世界最大的奖项！南非！
A world cup winners in 2019! The captain of that team was a guy called Cia Colisee, who was the first ever black player to hold that title, and the squad itself was the most diverse it had ever been. Cia, just tell me when the final whistle went, what were your first thoughts? You know, we face a lot of challenges, but you know, the Pueblo Sanfika have got in behind us, and we are so grateful for the Pueblo Sanfika. And, you know, we have so many problems in our country,
2019年世界杯冠军！那支球队的队长是一个叫西亚·科利西（Siya Kolisi）的人，他是历史上第一位获得该头衔的黑人球员，球队本身也是有史以来最多元化的。西亚，告诉我当终场哨声响起时，你的第一想法是什么？你知道，我们面临很多挑战，但你知道，南非人民支持我们，我们非常感谢南非人民。而且，你知道，我们国家有很多问题，
but to have a team like this, we know we can't put different backgrounds, different races, and we came together with one goal, and we wanted to achieve it. I really hope that we've done that for Sanfika to show that we can put together if we want to achieve something. It sounds like he's really like taking Mandela's example and continuing on into the next generation.
但能拥有这样一支球队，我们知道我们可以把不同的背景、不同的种族放在一起，我们带着一个目标走到了一起，我们想要实现它。我真的希望我们为南非做到了这一点，证明如果我们想实现某件事，我们是可以团结一致的。听起来他真的在以曼德拉为榜样，并将其延续到下一代。
Yeah, it's interesting. I mean, sports are political everywhere, obviously. But South Africa has been a particularly stark example of that just because of the transformation it's undergone, has been so stark. So obviously, you know, we saw it with the comrades in running. And this rugby story is just another interesting, significant example I think of a place you've seen that really powerful kind of transformation in sports in South Africa that mirrors what's been happening in the country. Does this mean I should watch the movie Invictus or I should not
是的，这很有趣。我的意思是，体育在任何地方显然都是政治性的。但南非是一个特别鲜明的例子，仅仅因为其经历的转型如此剧烈。所以显然，你知道，我们在长跑比赛中看到了这一点。我认为这个橄榄球故事是另一个有趣且重要的例子，展示了南非体育界那种强大的转型，反映了该国正在发生的事情。这是否意味着我应该看电影《成事在人》还是不应该
watch the movie Invictus? Roman, I want to leave that one up to you. Hahaha. I'll leave that decision between the audience and their God. Thank you so much. Thanks, Roman. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Ryan Lenora Brown, edited by Delaney Hall, original
看电影《成事在人》？罗曼，我想把这个问题留给你自己决定。哈哈。我把这个决定留给观众和他们的上帝。非常感谢。谢谢，罗曼。《99%隐形》（99% Invisible）本周由瑞安·莱诺拉·布朗制作，德莱尼·霍尔编辑，原创
music by Swansea. Sound Mixed by Martin Gonzales, fact checking by Graham Haysha. Kurt Colsted is our digital director, the rest of the team, includes Chris Barube, Jason Delion, Emmett Fitzgerald, Christopher Johnson, Vivian Leigh, Lashmodon, Jacob Molta-Narabadena, Kelly Prime, Joe Rosenberg, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. Special thanks this week to Isaac Inguenja, Roxy Thomas, Bob Dylan-Mott, Doshin Moodley, and Tommy Nitski. We are part of the Stitcher and Serious XM podcast family. Now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. And beautiful. Uptown, Oakland, California. You can find the show and
音乐由斯旺西创作。声音混音由马丁·冈萨雷斯完成，事实核查由格雷厄姆·海沙完成。库尔特·科尔斯特德是我们的数字总监，团队其他成员包括克里斯·巴鲁贝、杰森·德里昂、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、薇薇安·李、拉什莫顿、雅各布·莫尔塔-纳拉巴德纳、凯利·普莱姆、乔·罗森伯格、索菲亚·克拉茨克，以及我罗曼·马斯。本周特别感谢艾萨克·因根贾、罗克西·托马斯、鲍勃·迪伦-莫特、多辛·穆德利和汤米·尼茨基。我们是Stitcher和Sirius XM播客家族的一部分。现在总部位于北边六个街区的潘多拉大厦。在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。你可以找到这个节目并
join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roan Mars and the show at 99PI Ork. We're on Instagram, Reddit and TikTok too. You can find links to others to your shows I love as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. dot org On your marks get set stutter Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在Facebook上加入关于节目的讨论。你可以在推特上关注我@Roan Mars，关注节目@99PI Ork。我们也在Instagram、Reddit和TikTok上。你可以在99PI.org上找到我喜欢的其他节目的链接以及99PI的每一集往期节目。各就各位，预备，结巴。谢谢。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。